[Musik]
weniger reisewarnungen mehr als 80
länder sind keine risikogebiete mehr
sagt die bundesregierung und machte
zugleich klar urlauber müssen flexibel
bleiben welt machtanspruch chinas
kommunistische partei feiert hundertsten
geburtstag und mit den eigenen aufstieg
umkehrbar und film ab deutschlands kinos
machen heute wieder auf es ist ein
neustart mit hindernissen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend schön dass
sie dabei sind wie auch norbert lehmann
für den sport ein sogenannter familie
urlauber können etwas aufatmen bis heute
riet die bundesregierung wegen corona
grundsätzlich von touristischen reisen
ins ausland ab doch jetzt ist die
reisewarnung für mehr als 80 staaten
aufgehoben
die als crooner risikogebiete galten
darunter beliebte urlaubsländer wie
spanien italien griechenland und die
türkei
nur manche regionen sind noch
ausgenommen bei der rückkehr nach
deutschland entfällt damit die
quarantäne pflicht allerdings fordern
die meisten urlaubsländer bei der
einreise einen negativen corona test
großbritannien und portugal bleiben
virusvarianten gebiete wer von dort
zurückkehrt muss vorerst weiter in
quarantäne
britta spiekermann berichtet die
urlaubssaison läuft an den grenzen die
bewegungen frei aber nicht so frei wie
vor corinna die sorge die delta oder
andere varianten könnten sich verbreiten
ist groß die regierung zeigt sich
entschlossen zusammengefasst möchte ich
für den punkt der kontrolle sagen dass
die botschaft klar ist wer einreist muss
damit rechnen kontrolliert zu werden
ganz strikte grenzkontrollen soll es
erst mal nicht geben stichproben aber
schon besonders überprüft werden sollen
reiserückkehrer aus der türkei und den
balkan staaten
zurzeit ist kein nachbarland
deutschlands als risikogebiet eingestuft
an flughäfen soll es lückenloser zu
gehen die bundespolizei wird prüft die
digitale einreise anmeldung und den
status der passagiere gilt jeder der
sich in einen flieger nach deutschland
setzt und zwar egal wie das jeweilige
land aus dem abgeflogen wird
kategorisiert ist muss ein negatives
testergebnis oder einen gültigen im oder
genesenen nachweis vor betreten des
flugzeuges vorlegen das motto heißt
vorsicht allerdings sprechen diese
bilder von der em eine andere sprache
zehntausende in stadien auf tuchfühlung
laut weltgesundheitsorganisation trägt
die em dazu bei dass die korona zahlen
in europa wieder steigen
die kritik von bundesinnenminister ich
halte diese position der uefa für
absolut verantwortungslos die
infektionszahlen in deutschland sind
weiter niedrig urlauber müssen flexibel
sein die regierung passt die regelung
für reisende laufend an
für manche könnte das im schlimmsten
fall heißen harte landung in der
quarantäne
wenn sie noch mal genau nachlesen
möchten was wo gilt alle regeln und
fakten rund ums thema reisen finden sie
auf zdf heute.de und in unserer zdf
heute app zu den corona zahlen in
deutschland das robert koch institut
meldet 892 neuinfektionen binnen 24
stunden 100 16 weniger als vergangenen
donnerstag 63 todesfälle kamen hinzu
die bundesweite sieben tage incidents
sinkt leicht auf jetzt 5,1 die ständige
impfkommission ändert ihre empfehlungen
für astrazeneca wer die erste impfung
damit bekommen hat sollte als zweites
moderner oder biontech bekommen
der abstand zwischen beiden dosen sollte
mindestens vier wochen betragen
experten gehen davon aus dass der schutz
vor corona besser ist wenn auf eine
astrazeneca impfung eine mit einem m rna
impfstoff wie bayern tag folgt die
amerikanische finanzministerium spricht
von einem historischen tag für
wirtschaftliche diplomatie nach
jahrelangen verhandlungen haben sich 130
länder unter dem dach der oecd auf eine
globale mindeststeuer geeinigt
mindestens 15 prozent müssen
großkonzerne zahlen damit soll der
steuerflucht internationaler konzerne
ein riegel vorgeschoben werden
valerie haller an der börse in frankfurt
diese einigung ist schon eine kleine
sensation oder ja ein fast schon
solidarischer beschluss mit dem man so
erstmal nicht gerechnet hätte große
hochprofitable konzerne wie amazon
google facebook und co werden nun zur
kasse gebeten
jahrzehntelang haben sie ja geschickt
gewinne in länder mit niedrigen
steuersätzen verlagert und mitunter
weniger steuern als mittelständler
bezahlt schwierigkeit ist allerdings
dass die reform nur richtig greift wenn
alle zustimmen und da scheint auch bei
eu ländern noch so ein bisschen
überzeugungsarbeit zu leisten sein
außerdem steckt der teufel im detail
bislang zahlen unternehmen dort steuern
wo sie beheimatet sind künftig aber
sollen unternehmen stärker besteuert
werden wo sie umsatz machen ja und das
könnte bedeuten dass etwa volkswagen
bald mehr steuern in china zahlen müsste
also was das ganze am ende für den
deutschen fiskus bedeutet kann keiner
vorhersehen
auch der finanzminister nicht ein
schöner frankfurt valerie haller alle
sechs monate wechselt die
eu-ratspräsidentschaft unter den
mitgliedstaaten heute ist es wieder
soweit von portugal geht der vorsitz
weiter an slowenien
was viele mit unbehagen beobachten denn
der rechtspopulistische
ministerpräsident jantscher ist einer
der umstrittensten politiker europas
ihm werden angriffe auf meinungsfreiheit
und bürgerrechte vorgeworfen
wolf christian ulrich eisige miene von
eu-kommissionspräsident in von der leyen
beim besuch in slowenien heute kein
lächeln beim familienfoto
man hört von heftigen diskussionen mit
sloweniens ministerpräsident janez jansa
dann offene konfrontation vor der presse
wir meinen slowenien muss die
unabhängigkeit von medien garantieren
und öffentliche medieneinrichtungen auch
bezahlen
konkret geht es um die finanzierung der
halbstaatlichen slowenischen presse
agentur
sie ist hoch angesehen doch weil
ministerpräsident jantscher den eindruck
hat es würde zum kritisch über ihn
berichtet zahlt seine regierung seit
einem halben jahr nicht für die gehälter
beklagt chefredakteurin barbara stöckl
unser land ist immer noch eine
demokratie aber in einigen bereichen
sehen wir änderungen die zweifellos
nicht gut sind für sloweniens
internationale reputation
beobachter sprechen davon jantscher
folge inzwischen dem ungarischen vorbild
auffällig in der tat die enge
wirtschaftliche und politische bindung
an ungarns rechtspopulistischen
regierungschef viktor orban der vor
einigen tagen zum festakt des
dreißigsten unabhängigkeitstages von
slowenien
angereist war jantscher rechtfertigte
auch heute seine unterstützung für
urbans diskriminierungsgesetz gegen
homosexuelle
man sollte sich vor augen führen dass
wir in den 27 mitgliedsstaaten mit
unterschiedlichen geschichten und auch
kulturen immer wieder demonstrieren sie
in slowenien gegen den
ministerpräsidenten und hoffen dass die
eu ratspräsidentschaft das licht auch
darauf lenkt wie sich sloweniens
regierung von europäischen werten
entfernt
es ist ein besuch in zeiten des umbruchs
und ein besuch um abschied zu nehmen
bundespräsident steinmeier ist in israel
dort nimmt gerade eine neue acht
parteien regierung die arbeit auf und
präsident rivlin ist nur noch wenige
tage im amt vertritt sabine meyer
bilder wie diese gibt es selten zwei
präsidenten arm in arm bei den
militärischen ehren steinmeier und
rebellen bezeichnet sich als freunde
keine selbstverständlichkeit ein beleg
für das enge deutsch israelische
verhältnis
es hat eine symbolische bedeutung dass
das letzte staatsoberhaupt dass ich hier
begrüßen darf ihre person ist ein echter
freund mein freund die amtszeit von
riefen ihn ende die freundschaft der
beiden nicht so die erneute botschaft
aber es bleibt nicht nur bei
freundschaftlichen gesten steinmeier
bezieht klar stellung zum erneut
entflammten konflikt zwischen israelis
und palästinensern eine gute zukunft
wird es am ende dich geben ohne eine
politische lösung alternativen zur
zwei-staaten-lösung habe ich noch nicht
so recht gehört nach einem besuch in der
holocaust gedenkstätte yad vashem
folgten gespräche mit dem künftigen
präsidenten herzog sowie mit dem neuen
ministerpräsidenten und dem
außenminister gemeinsam will man
vorgehen gegen zunehmenden
antisemitismus aber auch beim thema iran
ist man sich einig ich habe hier noch
einmal unterstrichen in all den
gesprächen dass wir uns in dem ziel mit
israel völlig einig wissen iran darf
nicht in den besitz einer atomwaffe
kommen die botschaft dieses
staatsbesuches ist
deutschland stand und steht weiterhin
fest an der seite israels auch nach dem
regierungswechsel hier und wohl auch
nach der bundestagswahl egal wer dann
regiere so bundespräsident steinmeier
glücksspiel ist ein milliardengeschäft
online war es in deutschland bisher
weitgehend illegal von heute an ist das
anders mit dem glücksspielstaatsvertrag
will die politik den schwarzmarkt
eindämmen anbieter können jetzt eine
lizenz in deutschland bekommen
kritiker fürchten allerdings dass die
spielsucht jetzt erst recht steigt
annette pöschl hat details stefan börner
ist glücksspielsüchtig daran zerbrach
seine beziehung er unterschlug eine
million euro
sass dafür im gefängnis seitdem
abstinent sieht er den neuen
glücksspielstaatsvertrag der online
casinos nun bundesweit erlaubt kritisch
die legalisierung bedeutet ein
zunehmendes angebot von glücksspiel und
je höher je größer das angebot ist umso
mehr ist auch die gefahr in einer in die
glücksspielsucht zu geraten
genau das will der neue start-vertrag
verhindern die vorgaben spieler müssen
volljährig sein und brauchen bei den
anbietern ein verifizierte skonto darauf
dürfen sie maximal 1000 euro monatlich
einzahlen und für spielsüchtige gibt es
zentrale sperrdatei eine neue gemeinsame
glücksspiel behörde der länder in halle
soll das bundesweit überwachen mit
spezieller software und undercover
testspielern das problem
die behörde wird noch aufgebaut und
übernimmt erste aufgaben in einem jahr
das ist unterbindung von zahlungsströmen
und vorgehen gegen illegale anbieter und
dann eben nach dem halben jahr zum 1 1
die restlichen aufgaben sucht experten
kritisieren dass auch die bislang
illegal agierenden online casinos jetzt
von einem tag zum anderen legale
konzessionen beantragen können es
handelt sich um anbieter die auch streng
überwacht und kontrolliert werden müssen
und da wäre es halt gut wenn die behörde
leben organisiert worden nicht um
stefan börner findet der neue vertrag
bedient vor allem die interessen der
glücksspielbranche für die es um
milliarden umsätze geht china feiert
heute jubiläum 100 jahre kommunistische
partei und china feiert mao tse tung
jahrzehntelang der starke mann des
landes gewaltherrscher sieger im
chinesischen bürgerkrieg schließlich die
gründung der volksrepublik 1949 geprägt
auch von der verfolgung politischer
gegner und von hungersnöten bis hin zur
sogenannten kulturrevolution im jahr
1966 nach maos tod beginnt die
modernisierung wirtschaftlich aber kaum
politisch über das jubiläum berichtet
ulf röller
es ist ein ausdruck von absolutem
selbstbewusstsein
die kommunistische partei lässt die
armee ihre geburtstagsgrüße überbringen
nach 100 jahren fühlt sich die partei so
stark wie nie
präsident jean ping der mann an der
spitze steht im zenit der macht
wir werden den chinesischen traum von
der wiedergeburt der nation erfüllen
lang lebe die großartige glorreiche und
immer recht haben der partei
alle werden auf kresse den skis kommando
niemand darf abweichen von der partei
der trick bewusst den mao anzug denn er
führt das land genauso eisern und
unangefochten
der westen sieht mit sorge wie china
menschenrechte mit füßen tritt und
militärisch aufrüstet china hält sich
für das überlegene system wirtschaftlich
und politisch
wir werden niemandem erlauben uns zu
unterdrücken und uns zu versklaven
jeder der das versuche sushi pralle
gegen eine mauer aus stahl die 1,5
milliarden chinesen geschmiedet hätten
es ist eine kraftstrotzende botschaft
die china an die welt sendet das land
ist eine hochleistungs diktatur geworden
dass die wirtschaftliche abhängigkeit
des westens immer mehr dazu benutzt
seinen willen durchzusetzen das nächste
jahrhundert soll ein chinesisches werden
100 jahre kommunistische partei china
fühlt sich gut gerüstet für den
wettbewerb mit dem westen in die türkei
präsident erdogan hatte es im märz
bereits angekündigt heute nun ist das
land offiziell aus der internationalen
konvention zum schutz von frauen vor
gewalt ausgetreten
allein in istanbul gingen am abend
hunderte menschen vor allem junge frauen
auf die straße sie fordern die
entscheidung zurückzunehmen
präsident erdogan verteidigte in einer
rede vor anhängern hingegen den austritt
ganz anderes thema jetzt wann waren sie
das letzte mal im kino ziemlich lang her
vermutlich acht monate waren die kinos
wegen corona geschlossen ab heute dürfen
sie wieder öffnen unter auflagen
die freude bei betreibern wie besuchern
ist immens
susanne freitag berichtet das gehört auf
jeden fall dazu
die popcornmaschine läuft wieder anreize
eröffnet heute ihr programm kino in
saarbrücken nach monatelanger
zwangspause
das fängt noch mal an hier nach popcorn
kino zu riechen
ich habe endlich wieder eine anweisung
gekriegt welche werbung vor vorfilme
geschaltet wird also diese ganzen dinge
die in den letzten acht monaten so
komplett anders waren
heute öffnen die kinos bundesweit darauf
haben sich die betreiber verständigt
damit das geschäft mit den film
verleihen einheitlich ist bei der
hygiene und abstandsregeln aber gibt es
klärungsbedarf
jetzt stehen wir aber vor der nächsten
herausforderung dass wir wirklich
intransparente manchmal gar nicht mehr
verständliche auflagen haben weil ein
ort macht das anders als ein anderer ort
obwohl die gleiche verordnung ist da
muss endlich die politik ran 14 uhr 30
im größten kino von saarbrücken beginnt
die erste vorstellung kinderprogramm das
ist nicht voll aber es ist kino und ich
habe ihr versprochen wie ist kino
aufgeht sie mir die erst die lange pause
hat zumindest einen vorteil film mangel
gibt es im moment nicht das freut die
fans sozialisten rutter gerade was sie
sich alles anschauen wollen einfach weil
wir den vorteil ist natürlich auch haben
dass wir mit mega blockbuster staaten
nur neue filme haben also dennoch die
einnahmeverluste waren hoch die
konkurrenz durch streaming dienste ist
groß die kinobranche muss sich neu
aufstellen
heute ist von hier keine premiere aber
ein erfolgreicher tag war es für die
deutschen tennis cracks in löhne
angelique kerber hat die dritte runde
erreicht die wimbledon siegerin von 2008
10 bezwang die starke spanierin sarah
sorge storm mit 22 einsätzen und
alexanders werder überzeugte mit einem
souveränen auftritt gegen den amerikaner
tenniscenter der hamburger scheint sich
in wimbledon äußerst wohl zu fühlen
gegen tennis enkeln kann sich alexander
zverev von beginn an auf seinen starken
service verlassen und schlägt allein im
ersten satz neun asse ich habe mich
relativ wohl gefühlt klar dass ich den
ersten satz dann für mich entscheiden
kann ist glaube ich wichtig und danach
ist das hätte ich auch so ein bisschen
schneller gelaufen und ja ich freue mich
dass ich in die dritte runde
auch in seinem zweiten match verliert
alexander zverev kann ihren satz
gewinnt gegen central mit 7 zu 5 6 2 und
6 3
und könnt ihr in dieser form dem turnier
in wimbledon noch eine zeit lang
erhalten bleiben die deutschen
basketballer sind beim olympischen
qualifikationsturnier in split eine
runde weiter das team gewann gegen
russland mit 69 zu 67 und steht damit im
halbfinale
nur der gewinner des turniers mit sechs
mannschaften ist in tokio dabei jaden
sancho wechselt vom
fußball-bundesligisten borussia dortmund
in die englische premier league zu
manchester united die ablösesumme 85
millionen euro
ja und morgen die ersten beiden
viertelfinals der fußball-em beide zu
sehen bei uns im zdf ab 17.05 als erstes
schweiz gegen spanien
die eidgenossen eine der
überraschungsmannschaften des turniers
im achtelfinale hatten sie ja
weltmeister frankreich bezwungen
mit unbändiger leidenschaft hat sich die
schweiz ins viertelfinale und in die
herzen vieler fußball fans gespielt
gegen spanien fehlt den eidgenossen aber
ihr chef auf dem platz kapitän schack
heißt gesperrt ein herber verlust denn
er ist oft ein genialer passgeber so wie
beim 3 3 gegen frank
jetzt muss jeder spieler zehn prozent
mehr geben nicht nur um ihn zu ersetzen
sondern um das spiel zu gewinnen
ähnlich wie die schweiz hat sich auch
spanien im turnierverlauf gesteigert
nach zuletzt zehn toren in zwei spielen
zählt das team von luis enrique
inzwischen zu den titel-favoriten ja
doch das zweite viertelfinalspiel morgen
bei uns live zu sehen zdf belgien gegen
italien anschluss 21
vielen dank zum schluss noch ein blick
ins englische königshaus prinzessin
diana wäre heute 60 jahre alt geworden
zur erinnerung an ihre mutter enthüllten
prinz william und harry eine statue im
garten des kensington palastes da jener
die einstige kindergärtnerin ganz in
grau jeden tag wünschen wir uns dass sie
noch bei uns wäre erklärten die beiden
man erinnere sich an ihre liebe ihre
stärke und ihren charakter die königin
der herzen noch zum wetter es wird
langsam trockener und wärmer die details
hat gleich aus den termin viertel vor
zehn begrüßte klaus kleber im
heute-journal wir danken herzlich für
ihr interesse und wünschen noch einen
schönen abend bis morgen wenn sie müssen
auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
eine gute und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter mit der annäherung eines neuen
hochs aus dem westen verabschieden sich
die tiefs das hier zieht weiter nach
südosten die anderen beiden richtung
nordwesten
und dieses hoch hier das dehnt sich aus
trocknet die luft aus und erwärmt sie
gleichzeitig so steigen die temperaturen
wieder an
in der nacht ist aber noch tiefer
luftdruck im osten aktiv und es regnet
und auch im südosten fällt noch regen im
südwesten lockert es allmählich auf das
hoch macht sich bemerkbar die
temperaturen sinken dort auf 7° 15 bis
16 grad im nordosten deutschlands ja
morgen im tagesverlauf noch schauer vor
allem in den östlichen landesteilen
im westen kann es einzelne schauer geben
sonst gibt es im norden schon mal viel
sonnenschein und mehr davon im südwesten
bei höchsten temperaturen dort bis 26
grad und 25 grad richtung ost 19 grad am
kühlsten im vogtland die kommenden tage
am samstag gibt es schauer und am abend
dann gewitter von westen her bis 27 grad
ja und am sonntag wird es dann deutlich
unbeständiger und unwetter sind dann
auch möglich aber es wird wärmer damit
ein schöner ab